bon
il se dirige droit vers un ace plus le
petit pic de glace au monde se rapproche
de plus en plus mais on était au-dessus
de la partie émergée de pays d'aider n'y
a rien de pire que la mort d'un moment
nous avons une mauvaise nouvelle
concernant l'affairé qui l'empruntent
qu'on a prélevé sur la structure de la
victime appartient ton fils il doit y
avoir une explication
ils fréquentaient la même école jacob
était dans sa closing lainesse que tu as
fait arrêter mon fils
avant de démarrer je veux qu'on se
comprenne bien tous les deux quand un
jeune de ton âge est accusé de meurtre
avec préméditation
il est jugé en tant qu'adulte je vous le
jure je suis innocent
t'en fais pas on te croit
tu as dit à la police que tu étais dans
le parc est un des camarades a dit que
tu avais un couteau que tu apportaient
parfois au collège ils disent qu'il a
l'air prétentieux sans pitié cette
histoire elles poursuivent pour le
restant de sa vie
c'est un malentendu on va trouver une
solution avait des doutes quant à
l'innocence déjà glock non bien sûr que
non
où est le couteau maintenant
tout ce temps du moment j'ai fait ce que
ton père aurait fait
on va pas laisser sont testés entre les
mains du tribunal
mon seul boulot maintenant c'est de
protéger notre fils
les prisonniers dans notre propre maison
et on fait comme si on est énormément
franchement tu trouves que tout ça c'est
normal
vous trouvez les réponses nous mêmes je
sais ce que tu as fait les avocats ont
des limites
maintenant je n'ai plus aucune
vous rappeler qu'à leurs yeux il n'y a
pas que jacob qui est coupable voulait
tous est ce que vous m'avez suivi sauf
et compromettant
j'ai une pause thé en train dû faire
peur à bien qu'ils aient peur aussi j'ai
peur
et pour que je sache
je veux savoir la vérité
[Musique]
tu peux être un type bien où tu peux
être un bon père il n'y avait pas de vie
normale a retrouvé il y a eu un avant et
un après
[Musique]